thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first thousand people to click on
the link in the description can get a
one month free trial of skillshare's
premium
membership if you have a cat you've
probably witnessed them chasing down the
insects and spiders and other crawly
creatures that live in your home
our master of microscopes james has two
cats and so he is the beneficiary of
their combined hunting prowess so
james decided to turn that bounty over
to the microscope and to see how these
familiar creatures look when we see them
up close and also to see what
autofluorescence they reveal when we use
our fluorescent light
now this is a bit different than our
usual path into more microbial realms
where little droplets of water reveal
new worlds and new creatures instead
this time we're looking at creatures who
are quite visible and even familiar but
it's always fun to see familiar sights
in unfamiliar ways and to see what else
there might be there to learn
for example
let us talk about the silverfish now if
you don't recognize that name maybe the
silverfish sounds like an elegant
creature you'd find swimming in a
fantastical river but in reality they
are those tiny wingless insects that you
find scurrying around in humid spots
like your bathroom and our homes are
full of their favorite foods whether
that's the glue binding a book together
wallpaper or dry food in our pantries
and unfortunately we don't have footage
of the next thing we're about to tell
you but it's the kind of thing that when
you learn it you have to share it the
silverfish you are looking at right now
might be remarkably still but that
stillness conceals the heart of a dancer
when it comes time for reproduction male
and female silverfish have a whole
routine that they work through they
begin by facing each other and tapping
their antennae against each other before
backing away and then they repeat this
coming closer and then coming apart
until the male silverfish
runs away then the female tracks them
down and when she does they lay head to
tail vibrating with
reproductive intent
the male will deposit a sperm capsule on
the ground the female will pick it up
and from there a new generation of
crawling silverfish will be born
we do not have a fun story like that to
tell you about this spider for the very
simple reason that we don't
know what kind of spider it is all we
know about it is what you can see it is
tiny and green with little bits of white
hair and its eyes
if you hate spiders maybe those eyes are
kind of scary but we think they're
actually really lovely and a little
endearing
we also know that this was quite the
lucky spider because it was not killed
by james's cats which is why you can see
it moving around unlike this unfortunate
spider which met its end before we put
it under the microscope but it seems to
be twitching a bit when we turn the uv
light on now we didn't put our mystery
green friend under the uv light in case
that might have fried it to death
instead james decided to release it so
hopefully it is now off living a
wonderful life somewhere but we would
love to know what kind of spider it is
so if any of you know anything that can
help us identify it please let us know
in the comments
[Music]
now this however is part of a very
familiar insect they are the little
fuzzy hairs on a housefly's butt and
here up close are its wings with hints
of iridescence popping against the dark
background that color is not the result
of pigments it's a structure inside the
wing itself that bounce light back in a
way that produces the multi-faceted
filmy color we see
and when we turn the fluorescent light
on that iridescence goes away but the
patterns of veins running through the
wings becomes more apparent if we travel
further down we get to one of the fly's
feet which has some strange
autofluorescence at the side now we're
not entomologists but our guess is that
the autofluorescence is connected to
structures in the feet that help the fly
taste their food that's right
flies taste with their feet as they're
flying around and landing on potential
food they use the taste receptors on
their feet to get a sense of whether
their landing spot is actually edible
unfortunately of course those edible
landing spots happen to be my food or
yours but mostly i'm concerned about
mine now flies however are a much less
threatening household pest compared to
this one
the scorpion
now just to reassure you there was no
cat versus scorpion showdown to bring
you this image this scorpion was a
souvenir preserved and bought in
thailand and then brought to james's
home by the previous tenants of that
home
and when we turn on the uv light almost
the entire scorpion seems to turn blue
that's a handy trick for finding
scorpions in the dark you just shine a
black light and you'll find them glowing
around you but it's not clear exactly
what chemical causes this neon shine
just that whatever chemical it is it is
located in an outer layer of the
scorpion's exoskeleton that is why
scorpions that have molted and are still
growing out their new tough exoskeleton
will not fluoresce
now why does the scorpion do this we
don't really know but one possibility is
that it turns the scorpion into a giant
uv sensor able to detect uv light even
when it's nighttime so that it can find
darker places to hide in and from one
stinger to another let's end with every
picnic's favorite insect the bee only
the familiar yellow and black colors
have been rendered into a more orange
and teal combination here
[Music]
this image of its eyes seems even more
abstract
but maybe that's fitting because bee
eyes well
they see things differently than we do
they can't see red but they can see in
the ultraviolet spectrum and so just as
the way that we look through the
microscope changes the world that we see
an animal's eyes change the world it
sees
there are flowers with distinctive
patterns painted in ultraviolet a world
that will always remain abstract and
invisible to us
it's a world layered on our own
imagined with a vocabulary that can
never fully do it justice
but not all visions are meant to be seen
by us
sometimes it's enough to just know that
they exist and to bring what little
parts of them we can into our own world
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we'd also like to
again thank skillshare for supporting
this video now that you've been up close
and personal with some insects and
arachnids and have this new knowledge of
all the details that make up their
bodies skillshare is here to help you
put that knowledge to good use with
courses like insect illustrations and
animations in procreate you can create
beautiful images of your favorite
insects and artist liz kohler brown will
walk you through the process you'll play
around with colors and layouts that work
for your personal style in order to
create an insect illustration and then
you'll go a step further to learn how to
actually animate that illustration
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
world projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads to
distract you and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you and if you're one
of the first thousand people to click on
the link in the description you can get
a one month free trial of skillshare's
premium membership now you might be
asking yourself how does a channel like
this exist on youtube where there's like
chill narration and chill music and
chill visuals it's not like big and
flashy like a lot of what goes on this
platform well the reason that we can do
this is because there are people who
really like it and some of those people
when they can they help us out at
patreon.com journey.micro and these are
those people the people who make it
possible for us to do this and we are so
grateful to them
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby